hello there this is Steve Kaufman again
it's a Sunday it's a bit of an overcast
day here at Vancouver I have my son and
his family visiting from London pretty
soon we're gonna go out in our boat a
little rowboat with our crab trap and
put some rotten rotten fish in the trap
drop it down and maybe if we're lucky
this afternoon we'll go back out you
might have some crap for dinner can only
take the males and they have to be a
certain size er we have to throw them
back but that's okay
when we do find them they're very very
good very delicious very fresh today I'm
going to talk a little bit about these
various standard language tests you know
someone brought to my attention he was
on our format link
I should mention Li ng Q calm by the way
we're going to make that just the best
integrated environment and community for
language learning across all languages
in the world that's our goal but an
honor form someone mentioned that they
are going to be making changes in Japan
to their standard Japanese as a foreign
language test I can't remember what the
acronym was jl TB or something they're
gonna change the levels and stuff and
nord reminded me that here in canada we
have a thing called the twelve
benchmarks which is also a great big
thick manual setting out different
levels twelve levels with you know
detailed descriptions of person's skill
level and speaking and listening and
whatever and this took years of
committees of people meeting traveling
across the country whatever and I'm sure
they're continuing to refine it and
change it just like in Japan the JLTV is
going to be changed refined and they
undoubtedly have committees and experts
and linguists in jalawla gist's and
whatever else then we have these tests
like TOEIC in japan is leading
country in the world when it comes to
toy to million people in Japan take
TOEIC every year that's half the number
of people who take toys in the world
Japan is not one of the leading
countries when it comes to ability to
communicate in English but they are the
leaders in terms of taking the toy test
we have many foreign students who come
to Canada especially from China with
relatively high scores in TOEFL and I've
met these people and their communication
skills in English are not necessarily
all that great the we have the Cambridge
tests or IELTS or whatever there's all
these different tests some of them as in
the tol a TOEFL and all those are
commercial enterprises some of them are
and that's probably the better scenario
the worst scenario is when it's some
kind of a government supported
bureaucracy meeting regularly and
constantly refining and changing and so
forth is there any relationship what's
the need for these tests toi I mean if I
it's primarily for an employer if I were
to hire someone and I required English
language skills I would first of all
look out their application letter and
their resume any mistakes there and
they're probably rejected if it looks
well written if English is it was very
important if it looks well written then
I would want to speak to the person I
don't think I would pay much attention
to some kind of a Pollock result if I
were responsible for recruiting people
to a university of course the
universities actually want these people
in so they're probably motivated to let
the men regardless of their English
level but if if it if it was an issue
then I would want to see some examples
of that person's writing I would want to
see I would want to hear some audio
files of that person speaking
extemporaneously or even speaking in the
language na perhaps that's a little bit
time-consuming but if a foreign students
going to come to our University does
amaze
your commitment in time and effort I
think it's worth the worthwhile for the
university to make sure that the person
can make it another is can cope and
therefore they should put the time into
looking at some examples of this
person's communication in English
because we've seen too many examples I
mean all the university professors
complain that people come with high
TOEFL scores who simply can't cope
I think TOEIC in the sense that it's the
least expensive and the simplest is
probably the best of these tests insofar
as English is concerned it's inexpensive
because there is no output so it's a
measure it doesn't say that the person
can communicate but it's a measure
someone who is at an 800 mm TOEIC is
better than someone who's at a foreigner
and is relatively objective the value of
what it measures is not clear but it's
relatively objective I mean we're not
talking here about engineers and doctors
or electricians people who have that
have to have very specific skills in
order to perform a specific task we're
talking about the ability to communicate
in a language and very often a person
who knows perhaps grammar rules or has
put a lot of effort into studying enough
vocabulary to do the test or they
whatever then those people may not be
able to communicate and yet I have
people who work with me in the office
who communicate spectacularly well and
regularly make mistakes
for example we'd have a russian
programmer with two Russians excellent
communication skills excellent able to
express itself better than many native
speakers on many issues in Russian they
don't have an article so guess what in
English there are no article whether
they speak English it doesn't inhibit
communication at all but probably on a
test they would be marked you know down
for that we have person who speaks
Japanese makes lots of sin you know
errors of syntax but this person
communicates with our suppliers with our
bankers with our shipping companies with
absolutely
you know it okay let's say I'm looking
for a translator
I don't need Toit or TOEFL IELTS the
equivalent in other languages when we
look for translators very often it's our
own members who translate for us our
interfaces so forth but many occasions
we have gone to pay for translation and
we go to this site prosy or pros.com PR
o z.com we say here's what we need to
have translated English to Spanish or
whatever it might be mr. Chinese we get
lots of people offering to do it at
different a different cost per word we
put up a short test for them we compare
who we think did a better job don't use
a person and never do I look at whether
they've got a poet degree or a JLT B
degree or a Cambridge test or whatever
so I wonder you know what purpose is
served by these tests let's take the
case of Japan does it encourage more
people to study English because they
know that their employer requires a
certain resultant toy yes to some extent
therefore you could say that the toy
test encourages people to study a
language you might not otherwise study
it but in fact if they end up nowhere
they really can't communicate they just
study for the test which is no fun so
they're getting discouraged
they're probably in many cases
demotivated in terms of any real
interest in learning language you know
is that really an efficient way to get
people to learn English maybe a lot of
those 2 million people who every year
take the toy test in Japan they have an
average result of something like 430 or
something maybe there would be there are
better ways maybe I go to Sweden no one
takes TOEIC everyone can speak English
but they have English television
programs they have lots of other ways to
encourage people to speak English now I
know Swedish is closer linguistically
culturally to English but maybe
everybody in Japan should be stir
maybe there should be studying other
languages that they're interested in so
I'm not saying they're a bad thing I
think obviously there's a need that
people feel a need lawyers or university
universities for assessing you know new
employees are applicants but maybe
they're relays maybe there are better
ways and maybe we shouldn't have all
these committees and experts sitting
around year after year twiddling and
changing and changing the levels and so
forth maybe that's really not that
relevant to the pleasure of language
marrying for its own sake and maybe it's
not that effective not effective in
making people in jargon on your studies
and and making them do better at any
rate that's my discussion for